-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
I am doing well,
not that anyone ever asks.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to the news.
President Biden traveled
to Detroit today,
but only because someone
asked him about Israel.
[ As Biden ]
Whoops, I gotta go!
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke yesterda
with Israeli Prime Ministe
Benjamin Netanyahu
and called for a ceasefire
in the fight between Israe
and Hamas.
Oh, good,
if anyone can solve this,
it's definitely the guy
who can't control his own dog.
[ Laughter ]
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy said today
he is opposed
to a 9/11-style commission
to investigate
the January 6th Capitol attack
And, in similar news,
Derek doesn't want you
to look in his sock drawer
especially way in the back
[ Laughter ]
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
announced yesterday
that the state will lift
its social distancing mandates
this week
for fully vaccinated people.
Okay, but, you know that's not
why people are staying
away from you, right?
[ Laughter ]
Former New York Mayor
Rudy Giuliani's son
Andrew Giuliani announced hi
run for New York governor toda
and told reporters,
"It's in my DNA."
Also sharing Rudy's DNA --
his first wife.
[ Laughter ]
Former Trump administratio
official Stephen Miller
has been accused
of trying to sabotage
New York mayoral candidate
Andrew Yang's campaign
by publicly endorsing him
in a series of tweets.
And Yang can sabotage
his own campaign with tweets
thank you very much.
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
yesterday released
his 2020 tax returns,
though, keep in mind,
he loves to underreport things
[ Laughter ]
South Carolina
Governor Henry McMaster
signed a bill into law yesterday
that requires death row inmate
to choose between the electric
chair or a firing squad.
Or there's always
the third option --
just pay the parking ticket.
[ Laughter ]
A Tesla car on autopilot
recently crashed
into a Washington State
deputy sheriff's patrol vehicl
and, now, the Tesla driver
[ As Johnny Carson ]
will likely face
a battery charge.
[ Laughter ]
Did you like that one, Wally
"a battery charge"?
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
an anonymous resident
of an apartment in Australia
recently posted a message
in the building's elevator
addressed "To the woman
[with] extremely loud orgasms.
[ Laughter ]
Can you imagine reading that
and thinking,
"Oh, no!
I sound like a woman?!"?
[ Laughter ]
Because, you know,
it's like when you hear your -
like when you hear yoursel
on voicemail,
you're like, "Oh, okay."
That was the monologue,
everybody.
[ Laughter ]